[Music]
voters here swing from conservative to
labor so changes in the political
landscape can usually reveal themselves
early here politically very little has
changed here and that's significant
because you would have thought that the
labour party could have taken advantage
of the fact that boris johnson had been
fined for breaking lockdown rules but
the labour party here gained just two
seats and they missed out on other key
targets as well
richard bakalitori is a loyal labour
supporter frustrated that they're not in
charge i want to see a labor government
give them a chance to give them a chance
because conservatives have been there
for quite some what they do doing this
just rubbish this rubbish
they haven't demonstrated what they've
been dislike preaching
karen and ian taylor were lifelong labor
voters but not anymore to return to
labour i would have to have a
working-class person
in some shape you relate to yeah yeah
they're working people
no party is in overall control here in
bolton but it's led by the conservatives
the town centers had millions spent on
it and that could be more important to
people than parties in downing street
sales manager anne penny is happy her
local conservatives are delivering for
her i'm absolutely conservative because
conservatives have done things in my
local area that i needed them to do like
what repaired the roads and the paths
near where i live model boat enthusiast
john goddard wasn't tempted by labour
but he's not totally sold on the tories
either talk of parties in downing street
or prime ministers being fined for
breaking lockdown didn't affect how you
were born no
the the what is it the criminal you know
the better it is
i've never heard that phrase no you mean
better the devil you know yeah that's
that's it
alex joins works in the theater in
bolton he says he reluctantly voted
labour this time
i'm not a big
labour fan currently how they're working
at the moment but anything's better than
the tours
the verdict here reflects the story of
the local elections it could have been
worse for the conservatives it could
have been much better for labour nick
martin sky news bolton